[Musique]
tout au cours de la campagne électorale
au canada les parties ont publié des
mesures qui ont pu être estimée par le
directeur parlementaire du budget
estimation du résultat pour les
contribuables pour vous et de l'impact
également sur le budget it giroux et
directeur parlementaire du budget à
ottawa
mais si giroud bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion expliquez nous le mandat que
vous aviez durant cette campagne pendant
la campagne électorale j'avais un mandat
qui est différent de ce que j'ai dans en
temps normal donc pendant la campagne
électorale les partis politiques peuvent
soumettre des demandes à mon bureau afin
que j'estime le coût des promesses
électorales qu'il compte faire donc les
partis ont l'option et n'ont pas
l'obligation ont l'option de me demander
d'estimer le coût des promesses
électorales et donc lorsqu'il y avait
des mesures il y avait des petits
documents qui étaient attachées aux
mesures et qui faisait quelques pages
estimation des coûts d'une proposition
faite en campagne électorale avec des
données précises donc vous avez fait des
calculs à partir des données que les
parties vous fournissez comment vous
avez fonctionner donc les partis ne se
soumettait une mesure qu'il comptait
annoncer ou qu'il considérait pour
inclusion dans leur plateforme
certains partis avaient beaucoup de
détails attaché aux mesures d'autres non
dans certains cas on avait tous les
détails dont nous avions besoin dans
d'autres non donc dans l'écho où on
avait besoin de retourner au parti pour
poser des questions on le faisait on
demandé des clarifications au parti en
question quand c'était assez simple ou
assez clair déjà dès le départ ont
confirmé avec eux l'entente que nous
avions donc est ce qu'on a bien compris
le sens de la mesure et ensuite ont
procédé à l'estimation l'acquisition des
données la recherche des meilleurs
modèles pour faire d'estimation on
fournissait un estimé préliminaire au
parti à ce moment de la partie les
parties avaient l'option de soustraire
la demande de la retirer ou encore de
poursuivre avec une estimation finale
est d'arriver en campagne électorale et
de publier la mesure où de ne pas la
diffuser de laisser tomber certaines
mesures
parce que les calculs n'étaient pas à
leur goût peut-être exactement donc le
service était optionnelle les parties
étaient avec la possibilité de recourir
à nos services mais avait aussi la
possibilité de ne pas publier un estimé
même si l'affiché aussi les annoncer
publiquement la mesure en question donc
d'après la loi
je dois recevoir un avis écrit des
partis politiques afin de publier les
estimer que j'ai effectuées en leur nom
il ya des partis qui ont pu laisser
entendre volontairement ou
involontairement que veut ni confirmer
leur plan de match ou approuver des
mesures
c'était pas le cas non le marocain qui
m'a conféré par la législation consiste
un stimuli coût des mesures électorale
et non pas leur bien-fondé ou non mais
nous leur à propos politique donc
lorsque je publiais un estimé le coût
pour certaines mesures c'était pas un
endossement de la mesure en arrière
c'était uniquement une estimation de son
courroux des revenus générés par ces
mesures mais comment vous avez fait pour
évaluer des propositions qui pouvaient
s'appuyer sur des sources de revenu
parfois est certaine pour certaines
publications
j'ai une équipe d'économistes et de
comptables qui sont très très ingénieuse
direct dans la recherche de sources de
données qui ont de l'expérience ils ont
aussi bâti des modèles sur au cours des
derniers mois pour anticiper un pli
mesure qui serait qu'il nous serait
adressé donc on a eu recours à des
innovations des mesures assez novatrice
pour estimer certaines mesures qui sont
qui sont assez nouvelle au canada donc
en comparant l'expérience de certains
autres pays où d'autres juridictions
on est en mesure d'estimer la totalité
de ce qui nous a été présenté dans
certains cas les estimations avaient un
niveau d'incertitude élevé en raison de
leur caractère nouveau ou encore en
raison de la difficulté d'obtenir des
données fiables et dans ces colons on a
indiqué que le niveau d'incertitude
était élevée pour ses estimations là est
ce que vous avez fait est ce qu on fait
ça ailleurs dans le monde on le fait
dans deux pays principalement on le fait
dans d'autres juridictions mais on le
fait principalement en australie au
niveau fédéral et pour un état et on le
fait aussi aux pays bas
mais au canada aucune autre juridiction
qu'il fait c'est une c'était une
nouveauté pour cette campagne électorale
isie
est ce que vous considérez que vous
aviez un pouvoir d'influencé sur les
mesures
c'est une bonne question je dirai que
par le fed estimé uniquement des stimuli
coup peut-être pas un pouvoir
d'influencé mais ce qui nous a permis d'
influencer le développement de certaines
plateformes
c'est lorsqu'on poser des questions
suite à la réception d'une demande qui
était pas très bien formuler c'est
arrivé à quelques reprises
on nous a soumis des propositions pour
lesquelles certains détails cruciaux
était nécessaire pour l'estimation donc
en posant des questions par exemple
avez-vous pensé à la date de mise en
oeuvre ou l'étendue où la clientèle
cible en posant ces questions là ça va
forcer les partis politiques dans
plusieurs cordes à réfléchir davantage
dans la mesure et dans certains corps a
retiré tout simplement certaines
demandes parce que les questions qu'on
pose est un suggéré que c'était
peut-être pas la chose qui voulait faire
vous avez un devoir d'impartialité très
clairement et de confidentialité
également oui un devoir de
confidentialité très très clair dans la
législation
c'est à dire que les parties nous
soumettent leurs demandes en toute
confidentialité
et quand je les mentionnaient on peut
publier les estimations uniquement une
fois que le parti nous fait savoir par
écrit
donc ce qui n'est pas un notifié par
écrit par les parties je dois le garder
confidentiel pour vous sous scellés pour
moi jusqu'à la fin des temps il n'y a
pas de date limite donc ça de voix ça
doit rester confidentielle advitam
eternam
vous avez plus de travailleurs avec vous
plus d'employés plus de moyens pour
faire tout cela
oui on a un cru notre nombre d'employés
au cours des 12 derniers mois et on est
maintenant un total de 40 incluant le
personnel de soutien le personnel qui
nous appuient en matière de
communication de ressources humaines par
exemple donc une équipe d'une trentaine
d'économistes et le comptable pour nous
appuyer pour m'appuyer dans ce travail
important et ce giro merci beaucoup
ça m'a fait plaisir